willkommen liebe zuschauer bei history
live den historischen quartett auf
phoenix willy brandt mythos und wahrheit
darüber diskutieren wir heute 100 jahre
nach seiner geburt mit dem
politikwissenschaftler alfred kuhse
frisch eingeflogen aus paris der
historikerin daniela münkel die unter
anderem die stasi-akten in sachen willy
brandt bearbeitet und dem spiegel autor
jan fleischhauer der die titelgeschichte
vor einiger zeit in sachen brand
geschrieben
es hat in sachen willy brandt in diesen
tagen fast den anschein als ob wir kurz
vor einer heiligsprechung stehen die
seligsprechung hat ja offenbar schon
stattgefunden verstehen sie dass herr
gross er ja denn in frankreich ist es
genauso neulich hatten wir eine tagung
mit löwen fürs per der ehemalige
premierminister von der von brand sprach
und etwas sagte weil ich gleich sagen
will
er sei angegriffen worden in deutschland
weil er den falschen namen hatte
eigentlich herbert frahm
in frankreich ist jeder stolz den namen
zu behalten der widerstand erhalten hat
und das ist ein großer unterschied
das mädchen bild vermittelt ja den
eindruck dass willy brandt ein
nationaler volksheld gewesen sein
aber hat er den gerade zu
regierungszeiten nicht auch da haben sie
nicht polarisiert kaum jemand damit
gerechnet glaube ich dass es so ausfällt
und wie sie richtig sagen zu
regierungszeiten und vor allem auch
davor war willy brandt derjenige
politiker der neben franz josef strauß
wohl am meisten polarisiert hat mittels
und wahrheit heißt unsere sendung herr
fleischhauer
was macht denn den wahren willy brandt
hinter all dem mythos überhaupt aus
willy brandt na gut ich glaube er es das
gewesen was es selten in der politik
gibt nämlich ein charismatiker
das interessante ist gerade seine
anfangs reden wenn man die hörten
nachliest relativ holzer zum beispiel an
es ist bei ihm eben wie bei einem
charismatiker auch diese diese aura der
die ausfahrt des vortages die auch schon
die zuschauer in besonderer weise
ergriffen hat und das ist es glaube ich
auch was die unterscheidung anderen
kannst dann was sich bis heute auch
gehalten hat diese charismatische kraft
und die hat natürlich auch etwas
mythisches ein mini stück biografie da
ist nun dieser mann er stammt aus
einfachsten verhältnissen ist unehelich
geboren geht in der nazizeit als
sozialist nach norwegen nimmt dort einen
neuen namen an nach leert nach
deutschland so wie berichtet als
norweger von den nürnberger prozessen
wird in berlin als deutscher junger mann
ernst reuters schließlich dessen
nachfolger es ein mann mit charisma und
zwangsläufig 61 kanzlerkandidat zweimal
erfolglos beim dritten anlauf klappte es
und er beginnt sofort mit jener arbeit
die ihm seinen platz in der geschichte
sichert mit der ostpolitik es wird ja
gern gesagt diese ostpolitik sei eine
ganz wesentliche voraussetzung für die
wiedervereinigung gewesen stimmt dass er
nicht ganz so zuerst einmal die
ostpolitik hat begonnen durch kiesinger
der erste brief an einen
ministerpräsidenten der ddr war von
kiesinger mit billy bahn als
außenminister und dann gab es die
möglichkeit in meinen augen 21 politiken
die von egon bahr und die von meinem
freund staatssekretär frank und egon
bahr war eine nationalistische
außenpolitik man sollte europa wusste
heute immer noch nicht was europas sein
kann und es gab vielleicht ein anschluss
an aber nicht eingegriffen in europa und
das war die eine politik und ich darf
vielleicht eine kleine anekdote erzählen
es war zur zeit der ostpolitik ich war
eingeladen mit datenbank von solchen aus
minister neue schumann der rief den
deutschen botschafter und sie haben
bleiben sie
ich muss nur sagen bitte sehen sie dass
wir noch in ihrem namen in moskau
verteidigen was er war schon aufgegeben
hat und zwar nicht dasselbe
die einheit darüber können wir später
noch sprechen dann nicht eigentlich
nicht der ziel bis zum schluss dass wir
auch die spd noch im januar 1990 maß
zwei verschiedenen systeme die geben ein
nebeneinander stehen mit als schlimmsten
stück das gemeinsame papier von spd und
spd das wirklich eine kapitals in die
logische kapitulation war jedenfalls in
meinen augen und die einheit
wenn der berühmte satz es kommt zusammen
was zusammen gehört einfach nicht dem
was brandt vorhergesagt werden
da wir über brandt sprechen ist es auch
richtig dass wir bei seinen engsten
mitarbeiter egon bahr sprechen wird das
eben waagerecht was als retro soeben
gesagt hat ich sehe das anders
ich gehe davon aus und man kann das auch
belegen dass brand und war ein
kongeniales team war was die konzeption
und umsetzung der ostpolitik anbelangt
wenn ich noch mal etwas zudem zu ihrer
eingangsfrage anhören was er sagen darf
die ostpolitik war ja so angelegt
anerkennung des status quo und
langfristig und dadurch lang dass die
überwindung des status quo mit der
langzeit sehr langen perspektive der
wiedervereinigung und brand hat dieses
ziel nie wirklich aufgegeben dass er
dann 1990 im gegensatz zu seiner partei
trat da ich denke darüber werden wir
auch noch spricht ganz sicher aber hat
denn herr fleischhauer die brandts
ostpolitik zumindest mittelfristig nicht
auch das system insbesondere der ddr
stabilisiert und wurde dadurch die
wiedervereinigung historisch gesehen
auch verzögert also zu der auffassung
kann man jedenfalls kommen man könnte
dafür auch argumente finden findet es ja
also ich glaube es in der tat dass ich
dann bei der charakter der ostpolitik
geändert hat am anfang ist es eine
politik die ein zustand beendet er nicht
untragbar geworden ist die
bundesrepublik hat er sich verpflichtet
zu allen staaten sagen diplomatische
beziehungen abzubrechen die ddr als
eigenständigen staat anerkannten das
ging eine zeit lang gut und irgendwann
wurde es lächerlich also irgendwann gab
es an kambodscha und die hatten dann
diplomatische beziehungen der ddr
angefangen habe es einen langen streit
innerhalb der bundesrepublik was man
einen mit kambodscha machen sollen das
heißt am anfang steht pragmatismus und
ich bin sicher die auch die cdu wäre es
wohl uns irgendwann zu der auffassung
gekommen dass diese politik nicht mehr
tragbar war
dahinter kommt plötzlich ein anderes
motiv und dafür steht natürlich schon
egon bahr sagen wir mal auch eine
annäherung an das system also dieses
dieser berühmte satz den sie zitieren
wandel durch annäherung na ja da kann
man nur sagen das gerät ja so ein
bisschen ins hintertreffen und ich
glaube auch spätes wird die nachher mit
diesen irrsinnigen krediten die nicht
mehr auf das konto von von brand und bar
gehen in der sich die ostsee sozusagen
in die neue regierung der stadt vor
strauss genau ist völlig das ziel außer
ebenfalls aus dem blick geraten
das andere system die stabilisieren zu
wollen mein mann hatte sich eingerichtet
in einer koexistenz
es gab mal eine große internationale
ausstellung algier
sollte eine große installation der
bundesrepublik geben
in letzter minute gibt es eine kleine
ddr ausstellung die bundesräte zugemacht
das war das irrsinnige an der politik
davor aber dann glaube ich
es ging das erfolgreiche war dass man
fernsehen konnte
das hat eine große rolle gespielt dafür
im osten lässt und westdeutsche
fernsehen ungestört sehen konnte dass es
doch mehr kontakte gab und so weiter das
war wirklich das erreichte ziel aber
ging es langsam zu es wird auf die dauer
zwei systeme gegenüber stehen und war
das möglich war dass tragbar an die
wiedervereinigung dachte an sich niemand
außer des bundesverfassungsgericht 73
dass die grenzen setzte der ostpolitik
im sinne man darf die einheitlich
aufgeben
und ich glaube das war ein urteil das
damals sehr schlecht aufgenommen worden
ist das aber dann nach rückflügen
berechnen verschieben und die einheit an
die glaubt dass muss man heute wirklich
sehen wer glaubte an die einheit motoren
vorher erhielt den gedanken auf zeichen
an die einheit kommen sollten sie nicht
auch noch also ich persönlich noch im
märz 90 dachte ich dass gorbatschow
niederlagen würde sie ganz deutschland
wieder nato zum beispiel und noch im
winter hat an glykol plötzlich die
unternehmer hof gespielt und ich muss
sagen im verteidigung von dieter k er
wollte 2 gegen die als anerkennung und
deutschland eingebunden europa nicht
angebunden an europa und das hat zum
beispiel auf die zähne des einheits
gesetzes gemacht da nämlich alle gesetze
und regeln euro der europäischen union
muss in den verschiedenen verfassungen
der neuen länder eingefügt werden und
das ist erst folge jetzt sind bei kohl
gorbatschow mitterrand alles
hochinteressant lasst uns zurück zu
willy brandt kommen willy brandt und die
wiedervereinigung retten siehe
angesprochen das ist ja zumindest
widersprüchlich da gibt es ja zum einen
den satz in hamm sie zitiert november 89
jetzt wächst zusammen was zusammengehört
und auf der anderen seite gibt es einen
satz noch vom september 89 hat er schon
früher mal formuliert dann wiederholen
die wiedervereinigung
ist eine lebenslüge der deutschen
politik wie passt denn das zusammen
liebe diskutanten dass das zu weil nur
ein zitat das wichtige ist seine
schönste rede in meinen augen weil ich
sehr voreingenommen für europa wenn er
seine rede als alterspräsident des
ersten vereinten bundestags und ich darf
das zitieren ohne die freiheitliche
selbstbehauptung des deutschen westens
und berlins hätte jede hoffnung unserer
landsleute zwischen elbe und oder
löschen müssen wir wissen auch unsere
freiheit hätten wir nicht mit vagen
können
wer sie nicht durch die atlantische
allianz und im wachsenden maße durch die
post parität und ist solidarität der
europäischen gemeinschaft geschützt
worden
zu den gründervätern des vereinten
europas ziel in diesem sinne der sollten
sie nicht vergessen die urheber des
marshall plan und männer die summen aus
meinen gesenkt aber die
wiedervereinigung ja schon vollzogen
aber ich frage was ist mit brunch
opposition vorher september 89
lebenslüge von würde ich nicht sagen
weil die entwicklung die dynamik der
entwicklung der folgenden monaten in der
ddr konnte keiner voraussehen und hat
auch keiner vorausgesehen dass brand
dann schnell auf diesen zug aufspringt
und ist er sieht es ja so als wenn es
die vollendung seines politischen
lebenswerkes ist das kann man
hinterfragen aber das ist die sichtweise
und er wird er dann sofort aktiv aber
die entwicklung im september die dann in
den folgenden monaten konnte keiner
voraussehen auch nicht willy brandt ich
glaube den umsatz wächst zusammen was
zusammen gehört sozusagen der willy
brandt der ja dann die wiedervereinigung
an der seite kohl zum gründen betreibt
zeigt sich wenn man so will gegen seine
partei gegen zeigten ursprünglicher
brand der der brand der anfangsjahre uns
auch der der anfangsjahre seiner
kanzlerschaft zeigen ja einen kanzler
der üblichen anti kommunist ist die
linke hat ihnen sozusagen anschließend
zu ihrer ganz großen ikone immer gemacht
und blamiert und willy brandt selber war
in dem sinne keinen
jedenfalls hat er keine illusionen über
die natur des des sowjetischen systems
die ohnmacht erfahrung als bürgermeister
dieser stadt in der wir diese sendung
auch aufzeichnungen zu sehen wie die
mauer gebaut wird und er kann nichts tun
er appelliert an die amerikanischen
freunde die sagen sorry das ist jetzt
nicht da wir werden jede keinen dritten
weltkrieg wegen euch anfangen diese
ohnmacht erfahrung die auch in seinen
erinnerungen beschreibt ganz am anfang
auf den ersten seiten ist eine zentrale
erfahrung für ihn gewesen und hat ihn
glaube ich imprägniert jedenfalls gegen
illusion wieder sowjetreich zu sehen ist
dieser spätere satz den sie dann zu
finden lebenslüge ist sozusagen der
politiker brandt
er sagt es wird nicht mehr kommen wir
müssen uns um wie einrichten weil ihm
die fantasie fehlt dass dieses system
was noch so mächtig eben außer
zusammenbrechen würde der gewissermaßen
über nacht politik stichwort ostpolitik
moskauer vertrag warschauer vertrag
vielleicht darf ich die frage vollenden
dann auf jeden fall war die zu diesem
zeitpunkt nicht doch auch alternativlos
anfang der siebziger jahre hätte denn
eine unionsgeführte regierung nicht
irgendwann auch die realitäten
anerkennen dass auch völlig ich habe
eine wette geworden die ich eingegangen
wurde
ich hab mit leisler kiep eine wette am
fernsehen gemacht dass die cdu die
ostverträge durchlassen wird in der
kleinen mehrheit aber so dass sie
durchkommen und er sagte nein wir sind
total dagegen
und wir werden eine kiste schon peinlich
bekommen habe
einige sekt und es würde ersetzt das ich
gemahnt hatte zwei flaschen champagner
das ist große bedeutung und zwölf
flaschen sekt sind zwei flaschen
champagner
aber natürlich war es klar und genau so
wie spd bekehrt hat zu arten aus europa
politik hat sich ein cdu erklärt zur
ostpolitik aber erst mit verzögerung ich
erinnere mich an die erbitterten
diskussionen 71 72 da waren ja die
vertriebenen verbände nicht nur diesen
sturm gelaufen es gab ja vertriebene
familien kam willy brandt kurz nach luft
luzifer da war ein regelrechter hass ich
erinnere mich an den spruch scheel und
brandt an die wand und solche
geschichten
woher kam das also ich kann es nicht
ganz teilen ich würde sagen die die
cdu/csu regierung hätte irgendwann auf
so eine politik gemacht aber nicht zu
dem zeitpunkt weil sonst die reaktion ja
gar nicht zu erklären wie sie richtig
sagen es ist ja das spaltet die nation
das ist das thema die leute deswegen
haben wir auch eine starke politisierung
in dieser zeit und zwar auf allen seiten
das ist das thema was die nation spaltet
und nicht zuletzt kommt es dann ja auch
zu dem konstruktiven misstrauensvotum
der auslöser ist die ostpolitik die
debatte um die ratifizierung dieses
vertragswerk und ich hatte das glück im
kanzlerbungalow zu sein in der nacht der
wahl 72 und darin nämlich noch gut mit
material schritt und wie die lagen sich
weinend in den armen und hätte nicht
ahnen können dass die scheidung dann
später stattfindet aber es war wirklich
ein großer moment im kanzler ein großer
moment
ein anderer großen der branchen
geschichte ist ja der berühmten kniefall
von warschau
selten hat sich ein deutscher kanzler so
emotional gezeigt die presse bewertete
damals den kniefall als eine geste mit
der willy brandt immigranten
keine schuld trug die schuld seines
volkes auf seiner schulter nahmen die
schuld war diese geste der demut
wirklich aus dem moment heraus geboren
oder eine öffentlichkeitswirksame
inszenierung anschlag eine inszenierung
erst zweites hatte nicht die schuld es
gibt keine kollektivschuld hat mir viel
gegeben ernannten last der vergangenheit
was völlig anderes ist und wenn ich
heute in hat letzte woche in weimar
gesprochen für 150 schüler sondern immer
es geht nach warschau sie das kleine
monument das da steht heute mit wieder
im knie fällt von willi bahn
er hatte keine schuhe keine
verantwortung die last der vergangenheit
besteht darin über als dafür zu kämpfen
wo leute unterdrückt werden das
gegenteil von was hitler machte das gilt
auch für die palästinenser das land all
meine these ist ja dass es keine
spontane aktion war und zwar vor dem
hintergrund dass brand genau wusste was
er tat und wie bilder wirken und dass
das gelegene ost politik viel zu wichtig
war um ein risiko einzugehen
aber die mystifizierung dieses krieg
kniefalls als spontane geste hat die
wirkung noch gesteigert
es gibt ja zum beispiel kaum bilder von
diesem ereignis von sven simon dem sohn
von axel springer das ist das bekannte
bild gibt glaubens zwei oder drei bilder
von dieser szene weil es keiner wusste
und es ist ja ein bild das gehört ja zum
bilder report war der bundesrepublik und
der welt
also mit frankreich war er seitdem der
große mann schlechthin
die zeit im kiefer eine umfrage
ihre blatt im spiegel herr fleischhauer
unmittelbar nach dem kniefall hat
freilich ergeben dass rund die hälfte
der deutschen bevölkerung die demos
gäste für übertrieben hielten die
deutschen damals noch nicht so weit die
größe dieser geste anzuerkennen gut das
problem war ja dann auch doch noch in
der zeit dürfen ist ja auch seine
kanzler werden von vielen als ein wunder
betrachtet worden
da ist ja ein mann der hat ein
lebenslauf der nun ganz anders als von
vielen deutschen als für den meisten
deutschen der spontan auf der richtigen
seite gestanden hatte im widerstand
gegen den nationalsozialismus und so
gemeinsam mit so einer exzeptionellen
biografie ist natürlich für alle die
sich irgendwie durch gemogelt haben oder
schlimmeres getan haben immer auch eine
belastung eine art anklage aha da hätte
man sich auch anders verhalten können
brand hat das sehr interessanter weise
dadurch geheilt ein bisschen es gibt
keine einzige rede von ihm in der er ein
vorwurf geäußert und er hat allen grund
gehabt bevor geführt zu äußern
im gegenteil immer verständnis auch für
die mitläufer gezeigt er so weit
gegangen zu sagen dass letztlich barnes
umarmung der mitläufer bis hin zu glocke
das war dann eine alters bemerkung schon
herrschen im prinzip für richtig wandel
für die nie falsch ist eine geste wo
sich jetzt viele deutsche offenbar in
dem moment gefragt haben und sagen für
wen entschuldigt er sich also für
entschuldigt sich für uns müssen wir uns
überhaupt schon wieder entschuldigen als
die berühmte frage
und das ist eben eine die bis dahin im
darm zu dem zeitpunkt das volk exakt
spaltet ich glaub 49 251 er genau da
waren die zahlen
vielleicht noch eines zu der spontanität
ich habe darüber mit schoss haatrecht
gesprochen sein redenschreiber der
glaube ich willy brandt so nahe
gestanden und auch persönlich als freund
wie wenige und paar precht hat gesagt na
ja es war so semi spontan also am morgen
hatte der kanzler im hotel in warschau
gedacht er müsste schon eine besondere
geste zeigen die geste dann der kniefall
das sei ihnen vor ort gekommen
darauf hat man sich jedenfalls
kanzleramt geeinigt gehabt als version
wirklich nicht es gibt keine dokumente
darüber und
man muss seine thesen haft alters an
manchem ich den polen war der ort
überhaupt nicht recht die hätten
vorgezogen dass er sich natürlich an man
mal wieder nicht im warschauer ghetto
das wollten sie eine geste die ein
bisschen fragwürdig war das vielleicht
auch ein grund nur als frage für das ein
potenzielles missverständnis bei den
deutschen weil sie dachten der brandt
kniet in polen wo er jetzt genau wussten
sie vielleicht sogar nicht genau
und sie war im grunde deswegen dagegen
war das möglicherweise missverständlich
sein zu können wir besser also ich war
es nicht auch eine gäste gegen den neuen
antisemitismus in polen können so
interpretieren dass klein aber ich weiß
es ich glaube es auch nicht ehrlich
gesagt das was sie sagen mit dem
falschen denkmal das in deutschland weil
es die deutschen nicht wussten wo er da
geklettert ist auch damals war die
wissen schon wo der metall und
interessant ist aber noch zu ergänzen
das empfohlen dieses bild ja unterdrückt
worden ist das ist ja erst nach der
wiedervereinigung ist ist dieses bild
bekannt geworden in dem maße viele polen
könnten dieses bild kann kommen und so
innenpolitik da war er zunächst mal
regierender bürgermeister von berlin 61
erst mal als kanzlerkandidat der spd
wurde im wahlkampf hart diffamiert willy
brandt alias herbert hahn seine
unähnliche geburt adenauer sagte
sinngemäß oder strauß war es glaube ich
auch gewesen
wir wissen was wir im dritten buch zu
machen
weinbrandt wissen wir dass ich viel das
damals alles auf fruchtbaren boden
ja also die umfragen sind da eindeutig
und brand kriegten massen von schnee
briefen aus der bevölkerung die diese
themen aufgreifen es ist für fleisch
sehr grün schon gesagt dass diese
biografie von willy brandt machte den
anderen
klar dass man vielleicht doch hätte
anders handeln können und das feld das
ist sehr wirkungsvoll gewesen diese
ganzen diffamierung es geht ja es geht
um die uneheliche geburt es geht um die
immigration
es geht darum dass er vermeintlicher
spitze für die amerikaner oder ob jetzt
je nach bedarf war das war und dann
kamen frauengeschichten alkoholkonsum
das ganze personal reden muss mitten in
den wahlkampf 61% letzte jahr der
mauerbau da profilierte brand sich als
anwalt der empörten westberliner die es
nicht verstehen wollten dass die
westmächte die mauer nicht einfach
sofort niederrissen wollte brand das
auch oder hat er nur so getan als ob er
hat getan als ob er musste wissen aber
da hatte ich meine erste kontakt mit
egon bahr der mich beschimpft hat weil
ich gesagt hat natürlich kann die mauer
gebaut wird mit erlaubnis des
amerikanischen präsidenten
die essenz die rede direkt davor sagte
der schutz von west-berlin der zugang zu
westberlin er sagte nichts über die
beziehung über ost west berlin und das
war eine erlaubnis denn es war weniger
welt gefährlicher als wenn man als wenn
zum beispiel westberlin abgesperrt
worden wäre nach westen
dass wir ein kriegsfall gewesen und die
mauer war es eben nicht es war die beste
nicht kriegerische lösung gegen die
flucht der bürger der ddr rang musste
das wissen was man die gründe dafür dass
er nicht nur 1 60 seien auch 65 also
zwei mal als kanzlerkandidat scheiterte
war die bundesrepublik so in der ersten
hälfte 60er jahre einfach noch nicht
reif für ein spd kanzler ich glaube in
der tat dass das kann bei ihm damals zu
viel dazu oder zu einteiler aufgelistet
man muss auch mal sehen seine herkunft
also sagen meinen 60er jahren ist man
gewöhnt
das kanzler professoren sind
er hat oder sag mal wie auch adenauer
aus ausgehobene beamten familien
bekommen und anderes mehr
brand ist der sohn nicht nur unehrlich
und einer kleinen konsum verkäuferin aus
lübeck das ist heute sagen wir mal
normaler geworden wir kennen wissen es
bei gerade bei sozialem karten wie
wowereit oder auch schröder dass die von
ganz unten kommen in diesem fall beide
mütter putzfrauen aber das ist damals
noch unerhört und dann kommen die
anderen belastungen dazu insofern ist
eigentlich nach dem zweiten anlauf der
zweite anlauf scheitert wieder ist
eigentlich die messe gesungen
er ist es gibt einen bericht von meinem
spiel kollegen hermann schreiber aus der
nacht er sieht ein völlig zerstörten
brand der weiß das war's ich werde in
diesem land nie kanzler werden diese
partei wird nicht einen dritten versuch
mit mir wagen und dann passiert
folgendes dass sich cdu und fdp so
zerstreiten
das kissinger den koalitionspartner
wechselt und plötzlich ist wie die brand
über nacht sozusagen wies der kanzler
einer großen koalition und damit ändert
sich das bild dramatisch und in dieser
großen koalition wurde er doch 68 fand
ja auch stadt zu einer art von
projektionsfigur für alle jene die die
verhältnisse in deutschland ändern
wollten war das also eine wesentliche
voraussetzung für diesen machtwechsel
der junge mit wenigen stimmen vorsprung
stattfand die anfang der 60er jahre
einsetzenden gesellschaftlichen
veränderungen politischen
auseinandersetzung haben den boden dafür
bereitet
und natürlich hat herr fleischhauer
recht wenn er sagt das war problematisch
bis mitte der 60er jahre dass so jemand
kanzler werden konnte aber wenn man sich
mal die wahlergebnisse anguckt was drin
wer so so schlecht waren die ja gar
nicht
61 36 265 und dann 65 über 39 prozent
und brand wollte auch 65 nicht mehr hat
von sich aus gesagt ich bin kein
kandidat mehr für dieses amt weil diese
diffamierungskampagnen diese tracks
kampagnen nicht spurlos an mir vorüber
gegangen sind er macht nach der wahl
eine 65 eine pressekonferenz und gibt
dann dieses statement ab als dann 66 der
ruf nach bonn kommt ist ja auch erst
sehr zugänglich er ist er nimmt ja nicht
gleich die chance wahr und sagt ich will
jetzt unbedingt außenminister werden
sondern zögert nicht zuletzt weil er
einer großen koalition beziehungsweise
den personellen der personellen
besetzung doch etwas kritisch gegenüber
stand und dann kommt hinzu dass wirklich
die große koalition gut funktioniert hat
teilweise durch carsten seiner besten
rolle als staatssekretär und er wurde
dann würdig mehr zu sein da bewiesen
hatte dass er was ist und die koalition
hat gut regiert spreche ich von
zukünftigen ecke koalitionen und ich
glaube wirklich dass hat ihn auch hoch
getragen ohne wurde dann würde ich ein
höheres amt noch zu haben damals das
halten das fest hat die große koalition
der sozialdemokratie genutzt
machtwechsel 69 fast fünf jahre kanzler
wenn man heute leute fragt was von der
kanzlerschaft willy brandt als
historisches vermächtnis übrig geblieben
es kommt man immer wieder auf drei
punkte
die ostpolitik den kniefall und den satz
wir wollen mehr demokratie wagen hat er
das ein gelöster fleischauer mit dem
mehr demokratie warum ja ich glaube
schon dass ich was das große versprechen
dass gruppen partizipieren dass man sie
auch brauchen demokratie die sich in
diesem fall eher ungebraucht am rande
fühlen
die jungen die aufmüpfigen die frauen
also das sind alles gruppen die zum
erstmal sich angesprochen fühlen wo er
auch ein thema in der tat ein trend
aufnimmt die gesellschaft ist im umbruch
interessanterweise muss man sagen dass
es bald erinnerungs märschen der 68er
gerät das heute so ein bisschen
hintertreffen
aber sie treten übrigens auch gegen
willy brandt auf die straße also als sie
täglich die 68er formieren ist im amt ja
nicht mehr
adenauer sondern nach kurzer zeit
kiesinger unter kanzler brandt also ab
69 die märsche auch gegen ihn insofern
das ist eine zeitung woche dafür ist er
die figur die die hoffnung gibt und die
ja muss man sagen menschen in einer art
und weise eben erfasst die ist danach
nicht mehr gegeben hat also da muss ich
widersprechen
in meiner friedenspreis rede von 1975
habe ich ganz hart die berufsverbote
kritisiert und brand war damals dafür
und ich halte den stolz im november 75
beim parteitag sagte brand wir dürfen
nicht an bei uns wohlgesinnten professor
aus paris überlassen
seine schweren bedenken anzugeben und er
hat er selbst gesagt dass seine haltung
damals bei den berufsverboten nicht gut
gewesen ist dass ein ist also sagen wir
mal gesellschaftlichen gruppen wie zum
beispiel der jugend den frauen anleihen
mehr das gefühl zu geben wir brauchen
euch auch das andere ist ob man nun
extremisten im staatsdienst haben will
da muss ich sagen kann ihm die andere
seite von brannten durch anderter
antikommunist dass er das später als
seinen größten fehler bezeichnet hat ist
dann vielleicht mögen sie auch die
altersmilde sie einsetzt wenn man die
wesentliche zeit darauf podien und
konferenzen verbringt und nicht mehr im
kanzleramt in der frage war nun
eindeutig dass es in der zeit auch gar
keine wissens qual bereitet mehr
demokratie wagen von mücke hatte die
bundesrepublik der späten 60er und
frühen 70er jahre es nötig dass mehr
demokratie gebraucht wurde wir haben ja
es ist er im gang es geht ja letztlich
mit der spiegel-affäre los die spiegel
affäre ist der auslöser dass über diese
demokratisierung
wenige demokratisierung der
bundesrepublik gesprochen wird auf
breiter basis und das entwickelt sich
dann weiter immer mehr gesellschaftliche
gruppen intellektuelle machen sich stark
ist das dass es notwendig sei sich mit
der ns vergangenheit auseinanderzusetzen
und ein demokratischeres staatswesen das
heißt natürlich nicht dass die
bundesrepublik vor 1969 undemokratisch
war das muss man aber da hat der
fleischhauer sehr recht dieses mehr
demokratie wagen zielt auf eine stärkere
partizipation und emanzipation der
bürger ab und was ja auch umgesetzt wird
wir haben 1972 eine wahlbeteiligung von
über 90 prozent also das ist ja heute
kaum mehr vorstellbar wir haben auf
allen ebenen tausende von menschen die
sich politisch engagieren in den
sozialdemokratischen wähler initiativen
künstler intellektuelle ganz normale
bürger sind es ist eine massenbewegung
1972 und da das hat es in der form nicht
wiedergegeben in der alten
bundesrepublik ihm sehr dankbar dass sie
das ansprechen denn es gibt mir
gelegenheit diesen wunderschönen button
zu zeigen aus dem legendären wahlkampf
72 den beschritt er mit der aura des
friedens nobelpreisträger willy wählen
war das stichwort die original plakette
ist das hier die hatte man als gutmensch
damals anzustecken nicht wenige sahen in
ihm damals auch eine art von erlöser ich
erinnere mich an diesem wahlkampf wie
ist das zu erklären
dieser wandel von 60er jahre auf den
erlöser 72 in der bevölkerung großen
teilen der bevölkerung das sind die
charismatischen kräften natürlich auch
die es ist ja so ein mann der auch so
angegriffen wird
da gibt es ja auch ein gefühl in der
bevölkerung natürlich dass das ist dass
fairness gefühl berührt gewesen
ich glaube selbst bei leuten die
die jetzt nicht unbedingt mit seiner
sympathie mit seiner politik sympathie
hatten die waren ja wirklich maßlos
straßen anderes mehr
und auf der anderen seite ja also das
ist ich erinnere mich an meine früheste
politische kindheitserinnerung ist
misstrauensvotum gegen willy brandt
meine mutter steht küchenradio sie war
keine gläubige christin ganz im
gegenteil ich könnte schwören ihre
lippen haben sich bewegt bei der
stimmauszählung und es geht ein es
fließen tränen als der feige anschlag
der union an unserem kanzler vorbeigeht
eine große rolle da bin ich ganz bei ihm
aber es ist es nicht sind natürlich auch
die erfolge dieser politik diese ersten
drei jahre der kanzlerschaft es ist ja
sehr sehr dynamisch da passiert hier
unheimlich viel
die ostpolitik aber auch innenpolitische
reformen wenn ja welche sind es denn
vielleicht ergebe dass man unseren
zuschauern weil kaum einer weiß noch was
sind die innenpolitischen reformen der
branchen zeit neben dem mehr demokratie
wagen
dazu gehörte auch nur größere soziale
gerechtigkeit
es gehörte vor allen dingen dazu ganz
wichtiges thema die bildungspolitik der
masse von menschen den zugang zu höherer
bildung zu gewährleisten und damit eben
auch einen sozialen aufstieg zu
ermöglichen strafrechtsreform frauen
spielen eine große rolle die rente wird
reformiert das steuersystem
es ist also es ist also ein ein breites
bündel von reformen angestoßen werden
die stockenden 73 aufgrund der
finanziellen lage ölpreisschock und
ähnliches und dann wird es schwierig
aber nur bis zum november 1972 ist ganz
viel angestoßen worden eben nicht nur
die außenpolitik sondern eben auch in
der innenpolitik
der moderator ist ein nutznießer
deswegen bin ich der regierung brandt
außerordentlich dankbar 72 habe ich
begonnen so promovieren und die
regierung
verkündete dass es graduierten
stipendien gab und die bedrohungen 800
pro monat waren ein haufen geld damals
für zwei jahre
also konnte ich promovieren also nicht
auch ein grund dafür war das nicht enorm
kosten trägt das ist ob das dann bereits
die wie die wirtschaftskrise
ab 1973 verstärkt auftrat und dann
stoppen diese innenpolitischen reformen
das ist dann auch mit ein grund für die
krise über die wir dann sicherlich noch
sprechen werden sich darüber reden wir
jetzt aber vorher noch herr fleischer ja
also ich würde also die die
innenpolitische bilanz ist glaube ich im
nachhinein er sehr viel düsterer
sie ist er gebaut komplett eben auf
letztlich auf schulden
es ist eine zeit ich glaube wir erinnern
uns auch ganz gerne deshalb zurück und
das finden wir jetzt alle möglichen sein
diskussion nach im fernsehen statt
viele bücher als ein letzter zeit der
unschuld sein der sender ewige frieden
ewige frühling dauernden wohlstands das
ist ja das gefühl indes mit dass die
sozialliberale zeit auch beginnt man
kann sozusagen ganz viele große projekte
in angriff nehmen und im zweifel erhöht
man bisschen steuern macht schulden und
als 73 in das ist eindeutig an dass ein
zentrales ja dieses plötzlich
schlagartig aufhört sozusagen der das
versprechen ewigen wohlstands ist diese
regierung von einem tag auf den anderen
handlungsunfähig und man belässt es dann
bei einigen
einigen einschnitten in
überdimensionierte sozialstaat programme
aber im grunde findet man dann lange
keine antwort
und insofern ist glaube ich das
vermächtnis von brand immer mehr auch
ein versprechen gewesen
als dann in der realen politik natürlich
schön es ist dass ich die wände bekommen
haben und darin lag ein gewisser weise
auch der reiz von brand ich meine es
gibt es gibt kein kanzler der so verehrt
wurde und auch wiederum so schnell
gescheitert ist er hat regiert habe
waren zum ende 45 jahren mit land da ist
keiner wirklich lange zeit für einen
deutschen kanzler
der arme helmut schmidt der hat sich wie
lange dort durchgequält dann 74 bis 82
immerhin ja also verschärften
bedingungen von ewigkeit kanzler kohl
und anderen gar nicht zu reden
das ist eine relativ kurze zeit und im
grunde ist er schon 72
interessanterweise mit der wiederwahl
amtsmüde
darüber reden wir das war ja der
höhepunkt der branchen amtszeit diese
wiederwahl
ein triumph 45 8 prozent für die spd
absolute sternstunde der partei aber es
war auch der scheitelpunkt von da an
ging's bergab wahns dem nur handfeste
ökonomische gründe vom mittel- oder auch
ganz andere mentale er wurde ja krank
der eben gesagt immer er musste ihn
morgens früh anrufen aufstehen will
regieren
er hatte irgendwie offenkundig auch
mental nicht so die listen hier zu
regieren das eine ist sind die sind
diese ökonomischen gründe genannt worden
sie sind auch ganz wichtig dass andere
ist natürlich das was sie sagen er ist
krank er muss sich einer operation
unterziehen er kann nicht mehr sprechen
er gibt er kann an den
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht teilnehmen
er gibt herbert wehner einen zettel mit
seiner vorstellung von von einem
kabinett der wird angeblich in der
aktentasche herbert wehners vergessen
sodass dieser zettel also diese
vorstellung von willy brandt gar nicht
zum tragen kommen er ist von helmut
schmidt mehr oder weniger sanft
gezwungen worden sein
kanzleramtsminister imke zu entlassen
ohne den er ziehe mich ja nicht nicht
handlungsunfähig aber der ziemlich zu
seiner handlungsfähigkeit beigetragen
hat das ist das eine ist kommt eben auch
wegen des stopps der der prüfung kommt
zusehends kritik an ihm auf die für ihn
liebenden intellektuellen bis dato fang
nun an ihn zu kritisieren
der spiegel macht dann 73 auf industrie
denkmal kanzler in der krise günter
grass l s via bildschirm mitteilen also
so ging es nun nicht weiter und er würde
nur ein brand wurde nur noch in den
wolken schweben
das sind alles gründe und es gibt
innerparteiliche kritik sowohl von
helmut schmidt der brand fehlende
führungsstärke vorwirft und anmahnt mehr
handlungsfähigkeit zu zahlen und
natürlich von herbert wehner der dann
aus moskau mitteilen ließ der herr
wartet gerne lauf was brachte ihm denn
dazu das war ja schon ein heftiger
angriff gegen seinen eigenen kanzler man
schmid hielt sicher offiziell zurück
aber wen er tat es nicht
schmidt hat sein mal ich auch schmidt
hat ein teil natürlich zu demontage des
kanzlers beigetragen was er wirklich von
diesem kanzler hielt dann vor allen
dingen in der schlussphase in hat er in
allen hintergrundgesprächen hintergrund
kreisen journalisten kundgetan ist stand
dann nur nicht wie bei weener mit seinem
namen verbunden
das ist ja wirklich eine eigenartige
ganz eigenartige geschichte bei brand
blick auf die st ich habe zwar den haag
recht gefragt wie das eigentlich sein
kann dass jemand der doch im widerstand
diese enorme fähigkeit den mut bewiesen
hat ich meine man muss sich vorstellen
brand kommt glaube ich 36 für einige
monate obwohl er auf allen möglichen ss
listen steht nach berlin eine torheit
arena
wahnsinn dass so jemand nicht die kraft
aufbringt zu sagen entweder wen er in
die schranken zu weisen oder sich
jedenfalls gegen innerparteiliche
widerstände so durchzusetzen sondern
reagiert hier mit mit mit rückzug
also immer wenn es schwierig wird nimmt
er auszeiten verschwindet plötzlich vier
tage in seiner dachkammer bezieht sich
die decke über den kopf und trinkt und
und dies ist natürlich für einen kanzler
seines seine freunde sind dann freuen
und sind verzweifelt sie sie drängen auf
dem kanzler ein nimm das heft des
handelns in die hand
entweder schmeiße wieder raus diese art
von illoyalität kannst du dir nicht
gefallen lassen oder jedenfalls bringen
die bahn und der kanzler entzieht sich
das verhältnis brandt wehner haben wir
zu reden vor allem im umfeld des
rücktritts also zuerst mal über schmid
schmid ist nicht alle bescheiden
also es gab die freundschaft zwischen
mieter und kohl und alle fragten sich
nach oben und ich habe ihm die antwort
gegeben weil sie beide von schmidt
beachtet worden
wirtschaftlich unfähig waren das stimmt
und wähler das ist für mich das große
rätsel woher kommt die stellung der
einfluss von vene der doch wirklich da
der königsmörder gewesen ist und onkel
wähler der sich unflätig benommen hat im
bundestag die die reden von venen sind
heute nicht mehr an hörbar mit der als
ein schimpfwort sondern vergangenheit
moskau ist total unklar geblieben
denn er hat wahrscheinlich doch
kameraden verraten
er war ein großer mann der
kommunistischen internationale und
onkeln wehner so gut so wunderbar warum
ist in deutschland in dieser stellung
gebracht das ist jene aber er war damals
der starke mann in der spd ohne ihn lief
gar nichts er hatte alle strippen an der
hans und offenbar hat das hat aber der
kaffee gelernt wie man so was mal bei
der kp gelernt und dann kamen ja
der rücktritt im frühjahr 74 angeblich
wegen georgen welche frauengeschichten
war das nicht nur ein vorwand war das
ganze nicht im wesentlichen ein
angestrebter machtwechsel im sinne venus
diese these gibt es ich bin kein
anhänger oder keine anhängerin dieser
these weil es keine beweise dafür gibt
willy brandt selbst hat zeitlebens an
diesen verrat von vena geglaubt hat das
ja auch in den notizen zum fall gehen
seine n als anhang zu seiner erinnerung
ist das ja auch publiziert worden
heute behauptet egon bahr selbiges und
auch frau seebacher vertritt diese these
die these geht ja davon aus jena fährt
ende mai 1973 in die ddr und trifft sich
mit erich honecker
kurz zuvor hat der chef des bundesamtes
für verfassungsschutz neue den
innenminister genscher darüber
informiert dass sich dieser verdacht
erhärtet hat dass ein spion nämlich die
jungen im kanzleramt sitzt die these von
von ba und anderen ist nun dass wir bei
diesem gespräch mit honecker hornig hat
das mitteilt zu sagen dass sie wissen
dass der spion da ist und ihm mit ihm
dann gemeinsame sache macht es gibt
keinerlei beweise für diese these es
gibt kein dokument und im übrigen
spricht auch dagegen die ddr hatte er zu
diesem zeitpunkt überhaupt kein
interesse dass die region brand in
irgendeiner form scheitert weil die
verträge mit der ddr seien ja noch gar
nicht ausgehandelt nicht insofern wird
da kein schuh draus main
apropos ddr sie bearbeiten ja die
stasi-akten in sachen willy brandt frage
gibt es da neue gesichtspunkte die uns
helfen auch in dieser diskussion
also jetzt über diese wähler frage nicht
in bezug auf das misstrauensvotum es hat
ja nicht nur geheime kanäle im vorfeld
der ostpolitik in die sowjetunion oder
nach in die usa gegeben sondern auch in
die ddr und egon bahr ist ja der
strippenzieher dieser geheimen kanäle
und der hersteller dass er auch
wunderbar und dass die russen ihm im
vorfeld geld angeboten haben um stimmen
zu kaufen
für die regierung brandt schreibt er in
seinen erinnerungen sagt natürlich was
auch stimmt dass er das vehement
abgelehnt hat aber er hat eben auch mit
den geheimen kann er in der ddr darüber
gesprochen hat dass auch dort abgelehnt
als als der hinweis kam das können wir
machen trifft sich dreimal in dieser
sache mit zwei verschiedenen ddr museum
und sagt dann aber natürlich nein aber
er spricht offen darüber über diese
ganze situation zwischen frage dass du
die gleiche ddr die ihn stützen wollte
einerseits auf der anderen seite aber
schon ein spion im vorzimmer hatte die
auslandsabteilung der geheimdienstliche
super-gau gewesen
vor einige jung war ja überhaupt kein
spitzenagenten der der kann ja gar nicht
an die geheimen dokumente ran er war
erst referent im kanzleramt für die
gewerkschafts fragen kontakte zu den
gewerkschaften ab 72 als kontaktmann zur
partei der der vag ein spitzenbeamter er
war für die ddr höchstens interessant
ein seismograph im kanzleramt was da los
ist und insofern das ist das schlimmste
was der stasi damals passieren konnte
dass dieser dieser spion aufliegt und
sie gerät dann auch sehr schnell
nach dem rücktritt in erklärungsnot
gegenüber der politischen führung des
des rücktrittes kam ja das thema brand
und die frauen groß auf natürlich ein
sehr dankbares thema für den boulevard
frau münkel fleischer findet sich denn
in den stasi-akten und in dem legendären
spiegel archiv etwas was uns da
weiterhilft war ein womanizer oder war
als er mich was ist wahrheit was legende
sicherlich aber das ist ja das eine das
andere ist ob diese geschichten stimmen
und in der form die sie dann kolportiert
worden sind sie auch nicht nachweisbar
und es geschieht ja in dieser situation
nach der verhaftung die jungs das
unglaubliche dass es gar nicht mehr um
diesen spion gibt sondern dass der
kanzler zum gejagten wird und immer mehr
in den fokus gerät das dann seine
leibwächter vom bundeskriminalamt
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz in die
mangel genommen werden und dann diese
geschichten erzählen und dann heißt es
plötzlich willy brandt sei erpressbar
durch diese frauengeschichten und es
wäre auch nicht gewinnen dürfen nur für
seine dritte ehe begangen zu haben
brigitte seebacher brandt denn hätte er
bei rot bleiben sollen na ja also ich
dem nur ein beispiel ein buch von mir
über die kanzler mit dem boden
vorgestellt wir laden wir die wand ein
sie antwortet ich komme mit meinem mann
wir haben zutritt zu abend gegessen sie
sprach ununterbrochen als das heißt sie
wollen sagen dass er jetzt sehr gebüßt
hat für seine frauengeschichten
geschichten was dran gewesen wie das
immer so ist
das schlimme ist ja muss man sagen sie
haben es erwähnt das ganze setzt der
wird ja in gang gesetzt vom damaligen
innenminister hans- dietrich genscher
und in zweierlei hinsicht muss man sagen
es abenteuerlich das eine ist man stellt
plötzlich fest dass der mann die
übrigens alle sicherheits überprüfungen
im kanzleramt durchlaufen hat dann schon
mal die verfassungsschützer all seinen
behörden geschlafen
ein mann war vermutlich der der des
ostens ist und dann zieht man die nicht
etwa ab sondern belässt ihn ein jahr
lang noch in der umgebung des kanzlers
wissen benutzt den kanzler als lockvogel
brand auch wieder in seiner
unnachahmlichen art guckt sozusagen über
ge um immerhin wegnimmt er gar nicht für
voll hält das überhaupt alles für so
komische geheimdienst geschichten die er
schon aus berlin kennt er nimmt das
nicht ernst
dann kommt sozusagen das raus die
verfassungsschützer in hohem bogen alarm
wir brauchen jetzt etwas sie können
nämlich gelogen nicht wirklich
überführen
und nun kommen sie auf die glorreiche
idee na ja er könnte ja möglicherweise
den kanzler mit belastendem höchster
belastendes material erforscht haben
frauengeschichten und auf anweisung in
diesem fall ist nur eine billigung ist
innenministers genscher werden also die
leibwächter unter druck gesetzt was habt
ihr eigentlich erfahren und dann werden
ganze listen aufgestellt ein paar dieser
damen wurden in offenbach
in der tat ist der nächste zugeführt
wobei dann auch immer die frage ist kann
die möglicherweise war brannten seiner
verfassung ist ein großer melancholiker
der ist auch gar nicht viel passiert wie
gewohnt hat das zum beispiel schöner
zugleich zu kennen die ist das alles
klar
sie erzählt dass natürlich natürlich
macht die band gehört zu den männern die
sich wohler fühlten in der gesellschaft
von frauen als von männern
was übrigens nicht in diesem fall gar
schlüpfriges sondern hat es gerne gehabt
sagen wir die auch eine bestimmte
weibliche intelligenz emotionalität und
sich wenn wie geburts da war die damals
die berühmte reporterin des stern war's
dann hat er geliebt bleibt doch noch ein
bisschen da haben alle kollegen
natürlich gedacht da ist jetzt was
gewesen
tatsächlich hat er gesagt hat dann neben
mir gesessen hat meinem hand
gestreichelt da saß ich noch eine stunde
wir haben was getrunken alles alles hat
so wild also aber wenn wir jetzt von
übeltätern im umfeld des rücktritts
gesprochen haben
über vena das hatten wir halbwegs
erörtert helmut schmidt und genscher
wurden
das haben wir noch nicht vollständig da
ist dazu zu sagen ja so vielleicht hat
genscher das getan was sie da sagen
aber ansonsten hat sich die sichtlich er
verändert sondern die spd sei es bei
brand sei es bei schmidt also bei brand
was dann später hat genscher dieselbe
politik und nachtisch mitmachen wollte
und schmidt ist von der partei deutsch
geworden und genscher hat mit kohl die
politik gemacht wie die politik von
helmut schmidt war also in diesem sinn
war geständig ein politischer hätte
zurücktreten müssen nicht der kanzler
umfragen kurz nach dem rücktritt sagen
auch die bevölkerung hatte heike diesen
hat diesen schritt für völlig unnötig
keiten aber brandt übernimmt die
verantwortung weil er die
sozial-liberale koalition retten will
und er denkt wenn genscher genscher ist
eine zentrale figur wenn er zurücktritt
könnte die koalition in gefahr sein aber
wie sagt genscher hätte die
verantwortung meiner branche ist doch
auch zurückgetreten als innenminister
und wurde dann ausgang
wenn er die in der jungen affäre
zurückgetreten wäre dann hätte er wohl
nicht kurz danach außenminister werden
können wir stellen uns ja heute der
frage mythos und wahrheit ist dieser
mythos auch und erst erwachsen als willy
brandt nach seiner kanzlerschaft frei
war und nicht mehr die mühen der ebene
beackern musste ich etwas zeit ist eine
enorme stärke dann auch wieder und das
macht das widersprüchlich an ihm es gibt
viele kanzler
die kommen über den abschied aus dem
beamten hinweg manche zerstört dieser
abschied wie wiesinger auch erhard ist
ein gebrochener mann anschließend
adenauer verbittert guckt er von oben
sozusagen auf das geschehen unter dem in
der rheinebene auch kohl hat nur
schlecht ist über angela merkel zu sagen
gab anschließend und war auch nicht also
alle kann zu haben grosse mühe
interessanterweise brand hat diesen
absoluten tiefpunkt es gibt es gibt er
schreibt ein abschiedsbrief an seine
familie spielt mit dem gedanken des
selbstmordes wenige tage vor seinem
rücktritt man sieht einmal es völlig am
ende und dann braucht es einige wochen
nur in norwegen und er ist zurück und
das zeigt seine enorme widerstandskraft
innere widerstandskraft beginnt ein
dritter eine dritte karriere als stall
sozusagen als als als als
vortragsreisender als vorsitzende der
international der sozialistischen
internationale und ist dann ja sozusagen
auch ein bisschen unser erster diplomat
im ausland hat eine fabelhafte drittes
leben und ein großteil seines glaube ich
auch nach ruhms verdankte in der tat die
sind dann die hat immer noch wie viel
wasser noch 20 jahren mit 92 18 jahren
reichhaltiger politik und auch in dem
amt ist er dann natürlich frei als er
nicht mehr bundeskanzler ist und das ist
das ist wirklich hervorzuheben diese
diese dritte karriere als elder
statesman die er dann noch international
hoch anerkannt als perverse nachfolge in
der präsidentschaft internationalen
wurde sprach er mit rührung und
bewunderung von willy brandt und wenn
man im ausland insassen parteien fragt
und wenn man die station und so weiter
fragt wie die band war auch der mann der
nach algier fahren konnte mit
einwilligung der partner israel und nach
jerusalem fahren konnte mit einwilligung
der aber das war auch seine
internationale verdienst meine
schlussfrage geht an sie alle und sie
können sich mit der antwort gerne zeit
lassen
adenauer brandt und kohle sind das die
wirklich großen kanzler der
bundesrepublik adenauer für die west
politik brand für die ostpolitik kohl
für die wiedervereinigung und alles
baute jahr wie gleichsam logik
aufeinander auf war es das bündel ich
würde diese reihung unterstützen
und zwar auch mit dem argument auffällig
ist halt dass brand nur diese kurze zeit
hatte diese fünf jahre aber in diesen
fünf jahren ist halt sehr viel passiert
nicht nur die deutschland ost politik
sondern auch eben gesellschaftspolitisch
selbst wenn diese reformen stoppen
die gesellschaft vor 1969 und 1974 war
eine andere
hinzu kommt dieses charisma und dieser
mythos willy brandt der sich inzwischen
entwickelt hat in dem essay war ja auch
schon mit gestrickt hat das darf man ja
nicht unterschätzen aber für die alte
bundesrepublik sind die drei großen
kanzler adenauer brandt und das beweist
so ein wenig nicht für europa
interessieren weil helmut schmidt auch
ein großer kanzler gewesen
er war der wichtigste von hatte er doch
nicht die großen historischen moment der
wandel der könig hat hatte den garten
ohne ihn und skistar gibt es kein euro
gebe es keinen maastricht-vertrag die
haben die weichen gestellt und das ist
ein enormer verdienst von einem dort
bundes solchen kanzler aber christina
selber hat gesagt die tragik von helmut
schmidt ist obwohl er der tüchtigste von
allen war sinngemäß dass er nicht dieses
historischen moment um hatte das brand
hatte und dass kohl später auch hatte
und ich die sie zitieren einen
kriegsverbrecher kissinger der 600.000
kambodscha zu tode gebracht hat der
30.000 leute hat foltern lassen im
chilly also über kriegsverbrechen
entspricht okay das ist jetzt also das
noch mal
sieben historiker fragt dann landet man
bei den dreien ich wir haben ja
interessant wie gesagt wieder ostpolitik
haben gesagt ja der in politiken
ich glaube der große für die das große
verdienst von willy brandt ist er hat
den deutschen die liebe zur demokratie
beigebracht und dass man etwas
pathetisch zu formulieren das ist das
was bleibt
und ich glaube in der tat dass ihr die
frage was macht ein kanzler zu einem
großen kanzler ist dass sie eben nicht
nur ordentlich ihr amt erfüllen darf
deswegen würde ich sagen die kategorie
fällt helmut schmidt dass sie eine idee
haben eine vision die darüber hinaus
weist das ist bei
das ist bei madonna auch nicht nur die
westbindung seiner dass aus diesem
deutschen volke noch mal wieder etwas
werden könnte
das sozusagen nicht alles verloren ist
es bei brand eben wie gesagt nicht nur
die die liebe zu dieser nicht nur
vertrauen liebe es zu dieser institution
zur demokratie und es bei helmut kohl
die vorstellung im das ist dass die
wiedervereinigung kommen könnte ist er
der einzige der in dem moment
handlungsfähig ist weil er diesen
glauben diese vorstellung diese idee nie
aufgegeben hat
deswegen überrascht es ihnen anders als
alle andere politiker in diesem moment
auch nicht und das ist glaube ich das
wohl im september 89 gesagt das ist eine
lebenslüge der deutschen politik holt
insofern ich glaube es braucht eine sbr
auch etwas was sozusagen über das
tageswerk hinausweist und am ende muss
man sagen helmut sportart ist ja gewusst
helmut schmidt hat sich auch wenn er
sich natürlich für den klügsten aller
kanzler immer gehalten hat dass da
irgendwas fehlte um in diese ganz andere
dimension vorzustoßen das ist ihm glaube
ich auch immer klar gewesen und er hat
nun das große glück allerdings dass er
anders als sein widersacher cool noch
sprechfähigkeit ist und diese sagen auf
jeden podium sitzen kann und natürlich
dass es etwas fabelhaftes wenn man
nachts arbeiten kann das für sie europa
keine große sache ist für mich ist es
eine große sache reden wir in dieser
schönen sendung im mai unmittelbar vor
den europawahlen und ich glaube schon
dass deutschland ein europäisches land
ist ein europäisches deutschland nicht
für ein deutsches europa meine damen
meine herren das waren die schlussworte
in dieser sendung dank ihn sehr
interessanten diskussionsbeiträge und
ihnen liebe zuschauer
danke ich für ihr interesse bleiben sie
uns treu